hello everyone I'm Jason Ben founder of
the
neighborhood and I totally did not
realize to cut off for submitting slides
so we're going to Freestyle the visuals
here a little bit um just ignore the
breadcrumbs they're going to be all
wrong uh okay so the neighborhood is a 1
square mile campus in the middle of San
Francisco and we help start autonomous
communities and hangout spots uh we are
Grand funded for the next two years uh
we that gives me time to build up uh
sustainable uh Partnerships with real
estate providers uh and that'll be our
business model um as for this kicked off
of movement piece um I basically just
drew a circle on a map and 20,000 people
saw it and it turns out when you spend
an absurd amount of effort justifying
why one square mile on the Bay Area is
the best in the whole Bay Area and
people are already willing to live in
the rough vicinity they are totally down
to move there uh and so it does feel
like a little movement um we we've also
inspired uh at least 150 people to move
I have kind of lost count uh We've also
inspired communities like
hfz uh which is an AI accelerator and
Solaris and mats maker space to start
here um so that's really cool uh okay so
mainly what I spend all my time doing is
trying to create truly excellent
co-living communities uh that is the
foundation of the
neighborhood co- living is where 10 to
20 adults usually live in one big house
and share a kitchen uh and if you're
familiar you might be skeptical it's
it's like kind of a niche subculture and
it's like really popular in San
Francisco but not as much elsewhere I
was certainly skeptical too uh but for
background my first co- living
experience started in 2016 when I
co-founded a house called the archive
here uh in the beginning we were an
ambitious but not obviously unusual
group of friends and over the next six
years the 15 founding teams in the house
co-founded companies that have now
raised $1.1 billion and co-author gpt3
which none of us would have ever
predicted
amazingly a third of those teams said
that the archive was pivotal to their
outcomes look at this bunch of normal
hippies I mean this is like very regular
and uh those are amazing outcomes so the
natural question is why don't more
houses like this exist like there was
20x more demand for the archive than
there was space so why are these
transformative co- living communities so
rare well the main problem is that you
need some really great people like some
of my housemates were just amazing uh
but great people are really hard to
coordinate
so if they're charismatic they have Rich
social lives if they're really
interesting they spend their weekends
building tentacle robots or hacking
Afghanistan which are both real stories
uh and so how do you start many new ones
I uh it's hard to say so one key Insight
came from the unconferences I've been
going to uh an unconference is like a
conference like this except it's much
smaller and everyone gives an informal
talk about anything they want and I kept
noticing that these events these
weekends kept producing really strong
senses of community and there's a bunch
of reasons for this but the main one is
that when everyone has a chance to
demonstrate their passion uh you're
often bursting with conversations by the
end of the weekend and you feel like
you're part of a special group uh but
unfortunately they always scatter to the
winds after and so this is one of the
key insights perhaps an unconference
could be a kind of archive Factory and
this could be the Keystone of the
neighborhood strategy so I set to work
and I hosted my first unconference in
March of this year here yeah here's the
right
side uh and it was themed around
climate so recruiting a great group is
the central challenge of this whole
project and so it's how I spend most of
my time uh unfortunately in January I
had all of five friends in
climate right I'm on
time uh so I told one of those five
friends about the concept and she got
really excited and she pulled out her
phone on the spot and she went through
three months of texts and she
recommended 25 different uh of her
favorite 25 of her favorite people in
climate right on the spot and and that
was when I realized that I could curate
this whole event through chains of warm
introductions uh which was great uh so I
wanted the bar for a warm recommendation
to be I want to be more like this person
in some way but I also wanted an even
gender ratio and I wanted everyone to be
at least curious about co- living in the
Bay Area and while I'm at it I also
wanted there to be representation from
all the different skill sets that are
relevant to climate and I wanted it to
be mostly Builders and at most 15% VCS
uh and those were a lot of constraints
for someone who's outside of the
industry so I built a tool to help uh I
made a live updating dashboard that
predicts the expected number of
attendees for each category given our
funnel metrics and conversion ratios
between funnels and I scraped people's
LinkedIn and I wrote I used GPT to
predict which categories everyone was in
and then I would send people this
document this live updating dashboard
before asking for their recommendations
and they would see that our goal for
non-male attendees was 40% but we're
only currently at 33% or that we're
looking for all these types of uh
technical skill sets but we don't have
any industrial Engineers or
oceanographers yet and lo and behold
when they see this document first 75% of
their warm introductions would be for
the categories we were missing and so
recommendations became
self-correcting and so over a period of
two months I went from six friends in
climate to collecting 300 Warm
introductions uh my EA and I researched
206 we invited 152 92 expressed interest
in attending 60 one ultimately attended
and we hit basically all of our
constraints almost exactly which was
amazing uh we aimed for 40% non-mil and
hit 37.7% which is not bad for a deep
Tech
conference we wanted at most 15% funders
and got 13.9% we want we wanted 19 skill
sets and got 18 Etc and despite not
explicitly seeking them 54% of the
people that came were our venture-backed
Founders which was interesting and It
produced critical mass for a co- living
house it it it seated a a medium size
group that started meeting with me every
week to recruit find a house and build
the culture that we wanted to uh
eventually start my sister even came and
got a job it was awesome uh by the way
event planning is a chaotic business my
original venue was covered by six feet
of snow 10 days before the event and so
I had to replan the whole thing so we
had to uh I I hit the original dates but
we had new chefs new venues and staff uh
however the new venue neglected to tell
me that their Decor was like The Party
Store vomited on Barbie's
dreamhouse it was for a singles party
for the owner's 60-some mom like the
next nightow and so we changed the theme
from climate to I love
climate we made a few tactical updates
of the
decor sweet
Earth always be mitigating your carbon
impact it worked out great so it
produced the chiness that we were hoping
for um but 61 people are Sly too small
and if you want to create a 15 person
co- living house in one Fell Swoop you
need to double or triple the size of the
event but that creates a new problem
which is that big conferences and maybe
we can relate to this here uh make it
really hard to connect with people which
is why we're all here so there're mostly
big group conversations and it's
difficult to justify a one-on-one
conversation when you're always being
interrupted uh in a chaotic environment
and so for my next done conference which
was 3 months later and themed around Ai
and Alignment I tried something
different um the basic idea was to break
up everyone at the conference into
groups of four for every breakfast lunch
and dinner throughout the weekend and
then I would dispatch them to local
cafes and restaurants within walking
distance and now they have 90 minutes of
quiet time uninterrupted to connect with
three other people in their group and
there'll be different groups all weekend
now I could have matched people randomly
and it probably would have been an
improvement but I really wanted to find
a way to make people to introduce people
to others that they really wanted to
meet um and so being being a former ml
engineer for you know 9 years naturally
I used AI so I asked everyone two
questions uh during onboarding I asked
what three questions would you love to
talk about at this event and summarize
your technical background and expertise
in a tweet and then I asked GPT for
every pair of people would these two
people have a great conversation based
on any of person A's questions based on
person B's expertise and that produced a
total preferences Matrix which I could
feed to the state-of-the-art matching
algorithm which is called the problem is
called theate roommates problem the
solution won in Nobel in 2012 and it
outputs given a preferences Matrix for a
group uh arbitrary subgroups of an
arbitrary size and so now I've got my
groups of four great uh and people
really loved it uh I know this from my
qualitative feedback but also because uh
a research scientist leading a team that
Deep Mind came up to me afterwards with
tears in his eyes and said it would be
hard to
improve and so now I've got the
beginnings of a repeatable machine that
creates communities that are both both
very well curated and very densely
connected
so the uh March climate UNC conference
did produce the nucleus of a co- living
house and after meeting with them weekly
for almost 5 months we finally found a
house and recruited the whole group and
they signed leases in September last
month they're called Treehouse and I'm
super proud of them I think they're at
least as warm and inspiring as the
archive was when we started and I can't
wait to do the same for AI for biotech
for sci-fi storytelling for abundance
policy for metascience for neurotech and
for much more over the coming
years The Vibes goal is to feel as cozy
as a small town as Lively as a
University campus and uh maybe the wild
dream is to maybe have a little chance
of kicking off a tiny Renaissance in the
middle of San
Francisco so if any of these tickle
you're fancy uh I invite you to connect
with the neighborhood of this URL and if
you're curious about investing in a
neighborhood real estate fund then you
can shoot me an email organizers
neighborhood sf.com and thank you so
much